hey reject nation how are you it's too
long of an answer don't need your life
story guys so many good requests check
out this video so many and I thought it
was Walking Dead related I'm like and I
caught up on The Walking Dead so I want
you I get out then I typed it in like oh
is now walking down o team darrell in
relation to in Thor have moved in with
Daryl when they were promoting thor
ragnarok way back when that's funny ass
video this is from the DVD I mean it's
uploaded on YouTube I don't know if this
can lead to the video getting blocked or
whatever
so we might have to cut up the reaction
portion but that's just a maybe we'll
see how this goes down
anyway team Daryl mega sided they're the
Grand Master's in this oh boy go blue
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
watch this so here's the first one
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
from the top
I guess I should practice this is mrs.
Richards
[Music]
[Music]
well he's going to rule beside his
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah this one as opposed to the the one
with Thor this one really amped up the
awkward I like that they have two
different flavors even though they are
kind of the same little sketch series
yeah because Thor is like fascinated
with human society yeah yeah Grandmaster
is just self-involved we got a little
bit more piano though I thought that
would have been funny I was like watch
him oh that's awkward man is this like
and he's this actual MCU cannon because
this is all produced from Marvel yeah so
I'm wondering is any of this actually
part of the cannon in some capacity do
we have a chance Darryl's gonna be a
biggie or Darrell in the MCU movies at
any point you have a chance he's gonna
show up at infinity War part 2 it's
gonna be like Darrell holds the key they
need to go to his company stuff yeah I
would love it if they even if they did
some type of like quick ready player one
cameo we're only and only the fans who
know they you know these these short
films of like oh it's Darrell or like if
Thor's I think that I think that that's
the kind of crossover Easter Egg I would
get truly excited for is like weird
little off to the side stuff like that
like oh cool that is that would be name
I mean I would just watch one of these
every few months like if they just made
this like a weird ongoing series I would
enjoy this is from the DVD itself yeah
you know as a special feature I could
see this as a TV series I could I feel
like they should do one but Daryl and a
diff
in character from the MCU ha every and
the Haggadah Bieber yeah they would be
the perfect picture they could feasibly
do stuff together
this is I left my buns off the laughs my
but we need to draw on him in the shower
it's like so creamy I can overheat the
same it gets like underlying like he's
like talking about making that phone
call to David's mom the awkward
uncomfortableness was really played well
got that that white titi flare oh yeah
absolutely all right well thanks for
sending that our way would have never
caught that appreciated I never look at
my special features on any blu-ray yeah
it's weird you go to the store and
you're like I want to get the one with
the most [ __ ] in it but that you never
ever watch it I always want to just get
a high quality blu-ray I have I'd and
rarely ever look at special features on
those things well okay I think I even
knew this existed it's a couple days ago
thanks mom thanks subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bow
porfavor and let's check you guys out on
the flippety-flip